and here is the man himself just off the
plane from Paris
we've also got the Sky Sports News
reporter all of Chen UI who's been with
him pretty much every step of the way
congratulations thank you what an
achievement and obviously you can never
have an easy Tour de France but looking
back how tough was this tour for you
it really was tough I mean they even
right up until the last stage even
though I had a four minute advantage
coming into the last couple Alpine
stages it still felt as if any one of
those stages it could go either way and
I think just just how unpredictable the
Tour de France is I mean one one second
I was there I had my four minutes
advantage it everything seemed to be
going on track and next next second I
was on the ground scrambling for a bike
and yeah I mean that's that that's the
nature of the sport and even even with
an advantage of four minutes things
things could have could have gone the
other way very quickly well let's talk
about that incident and all know you
were there of course but it was
absolutely excruciating to watch when
you fell off your bike was broken and
then you got on the second bike and just
watching you try and pull up that so
what was going through your mind at that
time it was it was absolute chaos up
there it was I mean obviously the
natural natural instinct is get back on
a bike and go again but that motorbike
behind us it had plowed into the back of
us as well and the broken broken my bike
basically so my my bike was this was
useless and I I just thought I'm about a
kilometer from the finish I know our car
with my spare bike is a while behind us
here I've got to get myself as close to
that finish line as possible I'm just
gonna run I'm just gonna head for the
finish line and hopefully the car will
catch me up and I'll have covered at
least a good good give them our distance
before before they do so you must have
been absolutely frustrated when you get
on got on the second bike and then you
were trying to pedal what was happening
there
that that that bike had come from the
neutral service vehicle that had been
following the race or not not from our
team and that bike was could have been a
kids bike actually with different
different pedals that weren't compatible
with the shoes that I had so just it was
it was almost comical at the time
obviously it wasn't very funny but
looking back now I mean yeah
sequence of comical events but
eventually then the team car did catch
up and I was able to swap back onto my
own bike and and finish the stage okay
Chris one of the other memorable moments
of the Terra Firma stage it that
remarkable descent and the night
infamous almost descending style when
you went on the attack many of your
competitors weren't expecting that how
much had you worked on that that that
really was a spur of the moment decision
it wasn't something I planned coming
into that stage or it really I just I
just saw the opportunity as we were
coming to the top of the climb the guys
looked as if they were just happy happy
in the group and I just thought well if
I go for it here what's what's the worst
that could happen they'll come after me
and catch me and I would have given it a
good go but when I went for it and I saw
that gap open up quickly to 10 15 20
seconds I thought I've got a real chance
here I could make it to the finish and
it did just feel like proper body boy
racing and getting it was just riding a
bike and trying to go down the hills as
fast as I could it was it's an amazing
feeling
it was great to watch about it as well
and it's interesting you say about it
being the feeling of a boy on his bike
again because for any boy watching the
Tour de France winning the Tour is a
childhood dream winning three is
unimaginable to almost every rider in
history have you managed to get your
head around the scale of what you have
achieved I think it's something it's
pretty
pretty hard to really get a sense of it
I mean it feels as if we're in this
little bubble that is the Tour de France
and it's it's what we do obviously every
day of our lives we're riding our bikes
five six hours a day training for an
event like that so it's it's pretty hard
to to really take it all in but I mean
obviously now
day after day after having won the third
time it's just it is starting to sink in
a little bit it's just such an amazing
feelings of feeling of accomplishment
and just knowing how hard the the
support team my teammates with we've
worked for months with with one goal on
our mind and to actually to pulled it
off and got to got to yellow got to
Paris in in the yellow jersey it's just
it's such a special feeling he always
gives such G credit to your teamster
Dave Brailsford has spoken in the past
about wanting to create the greatest
sporting team in the world not just
cycling team the greatest sporting team
how far along that road do you think to
you sky are right now I'd have to have
to say with we're not far off
we're not far off one of one of the
things that made this year's Tour de
France so special for me was not only to
be obviously going and win the race but
just the way that we did it we actually
had fun along the way the group of nine
of us all nine of us made it through the
three weeks it's the first time we've
we've got to Paris with all nine guys
still still there not having crashed out
or got ill or injured or anything like
that but that we actually had fun along
the way
as a group we gelled really well and
everyone just got stuck in and we're all
there with with a common common goal
Chris let's talk about the next two
weeks because you're going to be in Rio
very soon and that's just physically
such a huge challenge was there ever a
time where you thought or said listen
I've only got I can either do the tour I
can do the Olympics I can't do both no
no no that didn't cross my mind I mean
Rio
the Olympics only comes around once
every four years and to have the chance
to obviously represent Britain in what's
going to be in an amazing race it's it's
also a race which is very really very
challenging and to have this kind of an
opportunity that's that doesn't come
around very often at all so um it's it's
been a big golf since since we since we
saw the saw the rout out in Rio and yeah
hopefully hopefully we're gonna go out
there and then be as competitive as
possible what sort of things are you
doing to recover well I think the
biggest thing right now is to have a few
days at home a few days at home and just
just switch off mentally I think from
from that the whole hype around the Tour
de France and everything I think that's
that's probably the biggest part of
recovery and at least go into real fresh
and and ready ready for the next
challenge now we can't really talk about
Rio without looking at this ruling by
the IOC what did you feel about them not
handing Russia a blanket ban I can't say
I followed it that closely I've only
just heard her at the headlines but I
mean at the end of the day everyone
wants to see a clean fair competition
and for whichever way it goes I mean
surely there would be Russian athletes
who are competing clean and you wouldn't
want to see them and either so it's it's
a decision for the IOC obviously and I
just hope they make the right decision
for the interest of fair sport okay
let's talk about your inspiration now
because you have had a little Sun
recently so when you're going obviously
when you're in this sort of a race at
such a physical challenge but where does
it become a mental challenge and what do
you draw on then to get you through
those extremely tough times what are you
telling yourself definitely I mean that
there are there's only a certain
limit that you can go through I think
physically where you're just pushing as
hard as you can go but you almost get to
this point where anything beyond that
just becomes mental you against your
rivals and you have to push yourself
that a little bit harder than done
everyone else and and certainly that's
that's where you dig into the reserves
of what really motivates you and for me
this year
my son Kellen has has been a huge
motivation I I want him to grow up and
be be proud of his old man and and to
look back on on these images from from
from this year or he's too young now
it's it to really understand or anything
like that but I'd love him to look back
in 10 years time and to be proud of his
old man Chris you've already become just
the it man in history to when the tier 3
times or more but already people are
talking about the next magic number 5 no
one has officially at least one that
your de France more than five times you
know how much it takes in terms of
personal sacrifice hard work
sheer luck to win a tour de france do
you think it's a realistic ambition for
you to go on and win
perhaps another to two defenses is that
unfair any right now year this morning
it would just be yeah it's a bit early
to be talking about five but yeah I mean
I'm really every time I get to end of
the Tour de France I I'm really thinking
about coming back and fighting for it
again at the next year I mean just just
rolling onto the transit loser yesterday
I thought actually I can't wait to do
this again next year
I enjoy it so much and especially in in
the team that we've got around us it's
I'd love to you I'd love to answer your
question it's a dressing you say that
you're already looking ahead to next
year that's exactly what sir dear
Brailsford said to me yesterday when he
arrived back the team buses what is it
about at Serb rails pretty stein do you
think that's made Team Sky successful
apart from your talents to Riley Riggins
his talent what is it about him that is
me and Team Sky so successful I think
just as a as a manager he's been
really successful at choosing and
selecting the the right kind of people I
think to to work on this project I think
by far I mean it's one thing having the
the the the the cool bus and the bikes
and all the equipment and the gadgets
and everything but at the end of the day
it's it's about having that group of
people who really are driven driven to
to one one goal and when you've got nine
bike riders plus 30 40 staff on the road
who are all thinking and and acting in
the same way you it you're gonna put
yourself in a much better situation
obviously to to win a race like the Tour
de France and yeah I'm extremely
grateful to be part of that Chris I want
to ask you you're in this elite club now
everyone knows who you are but whenever
I speak to people who know you or have
interviewed you they always speak of you
as such a grounded individual how do you
not just buy into the hype and how do
you keep so grounded good question I
think is probably probably my family
that that they bring me or bring me back
if I do start getting a bit carried away
I'm sure my my wife would set me
straight pretty quickly okay it's been
an absolute pleasure thank you so much
thanks about